[Musique]
quand j'avais ton âge moi aussi j'ai
déménagé
tu vas t'y habituer on verra
on va être heureux là bas je te promets
mon ange
puis ce
nom ne t'ont fit plus jamais comme ça tu
m'entends
[Musique]
bonjour maman ou tu les a trouvés
vous avez déjà regardé votre enfant sans
parvenir à le reconnaître
il est méconnaissable
à mon attention
[Musique]
ce n'est pas votre fils
ne lui voulait aucun mal vous savez
chris lui rappelle notre fils défunt
que lui est-il arrivé elle était
convaincue
que c'était un imposteur
[Musique]
c'est pas crise c'est à lui
y at il des antécédents médicaux dans
votre famille
quelque chose ne va pas tu n'es pas mon
fils dis moi la vérité
je fais arrête de mentir et non pas
[Musique]
où
es tu
[Musique]